Ryan Reynolds is a man of many talents
and he is once again stepping into the
role of executive producer tonight on
ABC his new game show
don't premieres it's hosted by another
beloved Hollywood dad Parks and Rec star
Adam Scott fun fact
Adams salary is tied to how many times
he says the show's title Ryan Reynolds
makes a little fun of you - is it almost
an honor to get poked at with his
voiceovers they didn't tell me that he
would be making fun of me so this has
been a surprise I don't want to call it
a bone of contention but I'm extremely
litigious don't is exactly the kind of
physical comedy game show that Ryan
slash Deadpool would think of
contestants can win up to $100,000 by
completing hilarious tasks like eating a
jalapeno while on a treadmill just don't
drink they explain the show to me and
that Ryan was involved in that it's
self-aware it's sort of making fun of
game shows while legitimately being a
game show and that Ryan would be
narrating it some great comedy that's a
jalapeno pepper on top of it Adam Scott
I'm terrible at toppings the show is him
largely make poking fun at you you know
what Lauren there are some things that
I'd rather not discuss and that's one of
them you can just tell me don't I won't
go there Lauren dumped Ryan Reynolds has
many playful or maybe real feuds with
other celebrities it's funny you
mentioned Ryan
every time he rings me it's like please
can I come on your show I'll come on as
Deadpool I just want to dance I want to
sing with you from the moment I signed
on to dunked I had to sign a contract
saying Hugh Jackman is a mortal enemy
far as long as I live I have nothing
against him personally but as soon as
the show premieres I have to start
tweeting horrible things at him these
three actually have a lot in common
they're all funny and they're all dads
raising their kids
in an unprecedented time on a much more
serious note we saw of course that you
were joining protests over the weekend
we did not bring our our kids to the
protest this is a decision we made
health-wise but at home we showed them
when they see us and Malcolm X do the
right thing we've been and keeping them
up on the news want them to know how
lucky they are how privileged they are
and what a how different everything's
going to be from here on out at last
[Music]